enviarlas al operador del telescopio
y luego esperar ansiosamente que nos lleguen los datos,
mientras rezamos a los dioses del clima.
Apuesto a que la mayoría de Uds. no tienen profesiones
que dependan estrechamente de una noche nublada o despejada.
Aquí no tendríamos una segunda oportunidad.
El tiempo estuvo a nuestro favor, pero 'Oumuamua decidió no estarlo.
Su luminosidad no era constante.
Aquí vemos a 'Oumuamua desplazándose entre las estrellas.
Está ubicado en el medio.
Las estrellas dejan un trazo porque el telescopio sigue su movimiento.
Se desvanecía y se iluminaba de forma intermitente,
como cuando la luz solar se refleja en los cuatro lados de un objeto oblongo.
Los notables cambios en su luminosidad
nos llevaron a una conclusión increíble sobre su forma.
Tal como se muestra en esta impresión artística,
'Oumuamua es aparentemente muy largo y estrecho,
con una relación axial aproximada de 10 a 1.
Asumiendo que es oscuro, significa que tiene unos 800 m de longitud.
No hay nada en nuestro sistema solar que se le asemeje.
Incluso son muy pocos los objetos con una relación axial mayor de 5 a 1.
No sabemos cómo se formó,
pero pudo ser parte del proceso de origen de su propio sistema solar.
'Oumuamua variaba su luminosidad cada 7,34 horas,
o al menos eso creíamos.
A medida que recibíamos más datos de diferentes equipos,
obteníamos números diferentes.
¿Por qué será que mientras más conocemos algo,
más difícil se nos hace interpretarlo?
Pues bien, resulta que 'Oumuamua no rota de una manera simple.
Se tambalea como una tapa.
Así que mientras rota sobre su eje más corto,
también rota sobre su eje más largo y se balancea de un lado a otro.
Este movimiento tan energético y dinámico
es casi seguro el resultado de haber sido expulsado violentamente
de su sistema solar.
Interpretar su forma a partir de su luminosidad
depende fundamentalmente de la forma en que rota,
así que debemos replantearnos su apariencia,
y tal como se ve en esta bella pintura del artista espacial Bill Hartmann,
pensamos que 'Oumuamua puede ser más como un óvalo plano.
Volvamos a la energética.
¿De qué está compuesto?
Lo ideal sería tener un fragmento de 'Oumuamua
en el laboratorio para poder estudiarlo en detalle.
Pero como ni siquiera el sector privado es capaz de lanzar
una nave espacial en una semana
para estudiar algo así,
los astrónomos se tienen que conformar con las observaciones remotas.
Así, observan cómo la luz interactúa con la superficie.
Algunos colores se absorben y dejan una huella química,
mientras que otros colores no lo hacen.
Por otro parte, algunas sustancias reflejan más eficientemente
la luz azul o roja.
En el caso de 'Oumuamua, reflejaba más luz roja,
asemejándolo a la superficie rica en componentes orgánicos del cometa
que la nave espacial Rosetta visitó hace muy poco.
Pero no todo lo que se ve rojizo tiene la misma composición.
De hecho, los minerales con minipartículas de hierro en la superficie
también pueden verse rojos,
como el lado oscuro de la luna de Saturno, Jápeto,
que vemos en estas imágenes tomadas desde la nave espacial Cassini.
Meteoritos de níquel y hierro, es decir, metal,
también pueden verse rojos.
Así como ignoramos qué hay en la superficie,
menos sabemos qué hay en su interior.
Lo que sabemos es que debe ser al menos lo suficientemente fuerte
para no despedazarse a medida que rota,
así que posiblemente tenga una densidad similar a la de los asteroides rocosos,
o quizá sea más denso, como el metal.
Bien, al menos quisiera enseñarles
una de las hermosas imágenes a color que obtuvimos
con uno de los telescopios en tierra.
Lo admito, no es tan espectacular.
(Risas)
No tienen resolución.
Ni siquiera el telescopio espacial Hubble nos da una mejor imagen.
Pero la importancia de los datos del Hubble no son las imágenes,
sino que extendió nuestras observaciones
a dos meses y medio después del descubrimiento,
es decir que tendremos más posiciones a lo largo de la órbita
que quizá nos permitirán descubrir de dónde proviene 'Oumuamua.
Ahora bien, ¿qué es 'Oumuamua exactamente?
Creemos firmemente que es un remanente arqueológico
del proceso de formación de otro sistema planetario,
como material cósmico a la deriva.
Algunos científicos piensan que quizá 'Oumuamua se formó
muy cerca de una estrella mucho más densa que la nuestra,
y que las fuerzas de marea de esa estrella despedazaron material planetario
en los comienzos del sistema solar.
Otros sugieren que quizá se formó durante la agonía de una estrella,
quizá durante la explosión de una supernova,
causando desprendimiento de material planetario.
Sea lo que sea, creemos que es un objeto natural,
aunque no podemos probar que no es artificial.
El color, la forma extraña, el movimiento bamboleante
podrían tener otras explicaciones.
Si bien creemos que no es tecnología extraterrestre,
¿por qué no hacemos la típica prueba de buscar señales de radio?
Eso fue exactamente lo que hizo el proyecto "Breakthrough Listen"
pero, hasta ahora, 'Oumuamua no ha dado ninguna señal.
Ahora bien, ¿podríamos enviar una nave espacial hacia 'Oumuamua
y así responder a todas las preguntas?
Sí, tenemos la tecnología pero sería un viaje largo y costoso,
y estaríamos tan lejos del Sol
que el trayecto final de acercamiento sería muy difícil.
Pienso que 'Oumuamua aún tiene mucho que enseñarnos
e incluso podría haber más sorpresas
mientras más científicos seguimos trabajando con los datos.
Lo más importante es que este visitante lejano
nos demostró que nuestro sistema solar no está aislado.
Somos parte de un universo mucho más grande
e incluso podríamos estar rodeados de visitante interestelares
sin saberlo.
Este regalo inesperado
quizá haya generado más preguntas que respuestas,
pero fuimos los primeros en decirle "hola" al primer visitante de otro sistema solar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Jedidah Isler: Gracias, Karen.
Disfruté mucho de tu charla. Gracias.
Según recuerdo, lo descubrimos ya tarde en su viaje hacia la Tierra.
¿Será posible que tecnologías futuras como el Gran Telescopio para Sondeos
puedan detectar estos objetos con más anticipación?
Karen Meech: Sí, esperamos ver más objetos como estos
e, idealmente, nos gustaría descubrirlos en su camino al Sol
porque queremos tener tiempo para poder estudiarlos,
e incluso mejor sería tener una nave espacial lista para despegar,
estacionarla en las posiciones L4 o L5,
cerca de la Tierra,
de modo que cuando algún objeto se acerque podamos perseguirlo.
JL: Fantástico, muchas gracias. Una vez más, gracias a Karen.
(Aplausos)